hey I'm stayin today the video is a lot
different from past lie-detector videos
I'm gonna go to each of their homes have
them talk about their story from
beginning to end you seem upset was
horrific
toxic whoa this is really weird I kind
of like held that over him I was like
breaking up a few I'm a little scared
are you guys allowed to be like explicit
really hear both sides of the story
where things went well where things
turned sour if he leaves the room as
laptops on I'll like look at that their
chest story how it ended and whose fault
it was ask them all the questions that I
have yeah in your bag yeah at the end
I'm gonna have them strap up and ask
each other anything that they've ever
wanted I'm nervous does your mom still
hate me
do you regret dating me throughout the
time comment below who do you relate to
what have you experienced in the past
that was similar to this couple he would
always like ask me if I was like
cheating on him you have until you does
he know about it we've always done live
detective videos like back in 2015 when
I first joined we've done a few since
then with like try guys and stuff here
they want to share their story we can
always learn from other people on how
their relationships when Megan was free
and I grabbed her to help on the shoot
today I'm scared I'm a little scared too
I may seem innocent like a cat without
the claws
you may think I'm super sweet but like
line I'm gonna take you by surprise like
stranger in the night ready on that here
I come
by the end hopefully we can all learn a
thing or two of things not to do in a
relationship
strap up we're gonna jump into it how
long have you been in your relationship
two and a half years yeah how many
breakups have you had five see I've
never had a breakup Wow yeah my
boyfriend and I have been together for
10 years right we like almost had a
thing because I was doing long-distance
for like six months and that was really
hard so I'm really curious about other
people's I think there's a lot of
valuable things to learn people say that
people break up for like money sex and
kids like having children causes a lot
of issues what were some of the reasons
one of them I moved to Montana long
distance one of them it was just an
unhealthy relationship and we both
didn't like each other very much
okay that's important one of them was I
just know that you're not the one so why
waste both of our time you had
instinctual reasons I want to know
that's why I wanted to have them talk
about under a scrutiny of a professional
lie-detector guy John he scares me have
you seen him yeah he seems very business
it's not a toy God hates liars and I
hate liars the type of Stern dad that I
never had if you have nothing to hide
and tell the truth which way is the
secret front door do you want to
introduce yourself my name's Matt
LeGrande I dated Anthony the samito for
six long months you seemed upset
oh no no I'm good we had like a very
tumultuous relationship I want to know
all about that is this your family yeah
Laurie's my family looks insane I kind
of have a weird backstory like my family
are missionaries in Indonesia
like that's where I was born and raised
and that's why we look like a cult what
does that mean my parents are like
born-again evangelical Christians why
did they choose Indonesia Indonesia has
the largest number of UPG which is
unreached people group people who have
not heard the gospel who need to be
saved how long was your life spent their
first 17 years of my life
whoa tell me some happiest moments in
memories she bought me that plan it was
probably like this big when he got it
for me oh wow and now much unlike our
relationship it has blossom we almost
got tattoos together what would you have
done we were gonna get lying right here
yeah wow this is really strange
I hope these things still my place he
would like call each other lion-o and
then we found this and I was like the
big lion because I have a hairy back
okay I would call lion who clean lie
Anthony likes cooking he would come over
a lot when he would be like super drunk
like after comedy shows and then he
would just like make stuff in my kitchen
and make like a huge mess cute for like
a few months and then it was horrific
when you break up you're like Jesus
Christ why did I let this guy come over
to my house drunk and make ramen Tommy's
the beginning we met a Bigfoot lodge you
have comedy shows there I was booked on
the show that night bought me a drink
right after my set and introduced
himself and we like hit it off they have
a little patio area and we talked there
probably until clothes we made out on
the patio that night very stereotypical
gay ways we almost like hooked up in the
back home but they were like so many
people there two weeks later we were in
Tijuana together well you guys went to
TJ two weeks after that's a big vacation
yeah we're just like all in are you guys
exclusive during that time there was no
question about whether or not we were
open we're monogamous we're not seeing
other people yeah we've been dating for
like five months or so I was going home
for Thanksgiving and he had like told me
he loved me and I didn't say it back and
it kind of freaked me out he really
wanted like commitment had you said I
loved you before has anyone said it to
you before I had said it to a guy that I
was seeing before him I'd be like I love
you and he would be like I have a lot of
love for you it was always such a gut
punch her and it was really frustrating
for me I was just like a no Limbo's on
the whole time how old was he ten years
older than me do you like older guys
oh god
yeah yeah what is it about older guys I
feel like I'm getting interviewed for
like a porno think what is it about ol
Damon because I have like a weird life
experience it kind of forced me to grow
up quicker I was having a really good
time with Anthony but I question what
I'm having a really good time it's hard
for me to just do that I don't want to
like put too much pressure on the
Christian anything but there is sort of
the sense that like you are supposed to
be a martyr while you're on earth so
like if you're enjoying your time like
you should be questioning why you're
having fun I remember feeling really
guilty for not being able to commit am I
just not able to accept someone who
loves me what were some of the biggest
issues that you guys had
he was drunk so often three or four
nights a week one time I remember he
like threw up out of my what do you
think he drinks so much I think it was
probably because he was just new to LA
trying to fit in he's like a short
latino gay comedian one of a kind and
the scene there's got to be factors that
I understand from that either again like
a tall white guy and I blend in even
though I like I have a weird background
was there ever a competition element
with you guys since you guys were doing
the same profession that is like a huge
reason why I wanted to have a show The
Improv II didn't let me have a show and
then he started having a show there when
you felt jealous did you keep it mostly
internally or would you guys fight about
it there was like tension and I want to
know how to bring it up so much build-up
of like passive-aggressive stuff I
resented him getting things that I
wanted and then like definitely when he
said I love you I kind of like held that
over him and was like you might get that
show but I'm not gonna tell you I love
you
a part of me in ways didn't want him to
be happy because I wasn't happy about
where I was in my life we almost like
hooked up in the bra have you hooked up
in bathrooms before a I did in an
airport one time
and it was while we were dating after I
like knew that we were gonna break it
was a huge thing when we were dating he
would always like ask me if I was like
cheating on him and like Sodra man
why was he afraid alakazam when did you
tell him that you did it with the guy at
the airport I don't know if I did talk
to him about that you have until you
does he know about it but also I like
was kind of a denial myself about it so
I went home for Thanksgiving after he
told me loved me and I did not tell him
that I loved him
it was literally flying to my parents at
a layover in Chicago and there was this
like cute guy who was sitting next to me
on the plane and then like when we were
in the airport I went to the bathroom
and we were both watching her hands like
he made eyes at me and then he like went
into a stall and then I followed him in
and he just left the door open
yeah like unlocks it was like so sketchy
if that happened and then I went to the
terminal that I was on slept for three
hours and it kind of just felt like a
dream or something next week we broke up
when I came back you have asked me if I
like cheated on him and what was going
on I knew that I was gonna break up with
him it
I like kind of justified it like they
can't even count I don't even know that
person's name I've never seen them yeah
yeah I know where they were going those
things whether or not we like admit them
to ourselves like they affect you so
consciously he could obviously sense
that I was distancing myself okay whose
fault was it for the break-up the actual
breakup like moment I mean he was over
here literally making a mess in my
kitchen
and I was like I'm not gonna clean this
up it was like so dramatic I was like
breaking up a few and he's like fine
we'll have fun cleaning this up and then
he like threw the pot everything like
ran out so I think that one was on him I
think I was kind of the one who
initiated because I was being like kind
of withholding almost like self-sabotage
on my part I have like a hat urn of
being with guys who I feel like I need
to fix and do you fix them no okay but I
think it's this like Savior complex
being a missionary for 20 years
oh you're trying to save people I feel
like that's the whole thing that's what
you grew up doing I need to save Michael
program to do that Wow why don't I focus
on saving myself it's even interesting
like processing it with you because at
first like I was making it all about him
and how like he like drink too much even
talking with you about how a lot of it
was just my own personal issues was not
ready to be happy
here's what I want you to do write down
ten yes-or-no questions are you guys
allowed to be like explicit I can bleep
it up
so we just wrapped up with Matt I was so
happy that he was just really open about
their relationship their past and where
they are now
there's always another side to a
relationship I am gonna go talk to
Anthony so I'm getting some guests and I
just got a text from Anthony saying his
roommate isn't out yeah when he was
getting mad he couldn't ever have any
guys over Anthony is an adult he should
be able to have people who print his
plays I'm a little scared of his
roommate now you seemed a little anxious
I think we're good I'm relaxed now when
I first moved in here there was a
condition that I couldn't have people
sleep here it's like in Dilys he used to
have a tenant it was hooking up a lot
I'm just burying his baggage I'm like
talking solo okay let's talk how your
relationship with met I just thought he
was really funny
he's just striking in person a gorgeous
man you know I was just like wow hit it
off right away he's just very loving
that's the person he is to like his
friend but when it comes to intimacy
that's where he became kind of this show
when did you know you loved him we were
in bed and I was just like I love you
like and then and then and then like he
just hugged me it was kind of an
accident how long into the relationship
one or two months later on I think
Torres and I said you know the average
time couples say love you is three
months yeah and then he was just like oh
really in that it seemed like he was
like running away like we'd have like a
moment where it was appropriate to say
it he would turn it into a funny moment
or let me get on my phone and let me
call someone and he wouldn't let that
moment happen how did that feel like I
was chasing my tail of Kamath yeah I
almost suggested a couples therapy to
figure that out is it too early for that
he's from such a religious background
he's still kind of fighting this
internal battle what's the internal
battle you should be able to believe in
God even if he has like these Jesus
things he has an altar in his house like
I'm Mexican and he has an altar I mean
okay you know and that always might be
something a little bit there that's kind
of a tug of war you know like he just
came out tell me about your dating
history oh I've been through the wringer
with love when I was 21 I got with an
older guy how old he was like 36 it was
really toxic he was drinking a lot he
would like hide vodka in the house and I
would like find it and I was 21 so I
would drink it that lasted like seven
months wait why was he hiding it I
didn't know that he was like wake up and
drink alcohol okay yeah he would like
get the shakes in the morning if he
didn't have a drink
I dated another guy years later and he
ended up cheating on me Wow
so I was cheated on before he just
bucket out of your mind I think so yeah
the guy was a jerk and then after that I
really didn't date I was just focusing
on comedy I was like comedies my
boyfriend then I moved to LA I met Matt
and his gag comedian friends if he had
said I love you back did you see future
with him I think there could have been
the holidays were coming and he was like
I need a fresh start
that's what he said I don't know how
come to people your are talking about
this he mentioned like during the
relationship like you drink often was
that a issue what was the deal with that
he would drink too I came at you drink
until there was like a couple of times I
just forgot how much I drank before I
went to another show and then I drink
more and that was just like not really
drunk I was like accusing him of
cheating on me when I got drunk why were
you thinking he was cheating on you like
I would tell him I'm gonna be at this
show he would go to a different show why
don't you come to the show that I'm on
little things that raised a flag for me
and I guess he wasn't cheating on me
when you hold the phone away from
someone
for a good 30 minutes what someone's
texting you I'm happening maybe he was
just texting someone in the center it
was a private conversation with his mom
stuff like that
that I remember um yeah sometimes I'd be
like oh he just needs some space okay
that's fine but a lot of times I would
have that like panic I care what's
happening does he not want to spend time
with me how far into the relationship
did you start feeling that three or four
months in if he leaves the room
his laptop saw and I like look at that
third row did you ever do that no I mean
he doesn't know that mound think so yeah
there's a button that just tells you
what you've done what you've been doing
you know and it's right there but did
you ever find anything
no Travelocity or whatever I don't
understand what pushed me to believe
this I would tell him like it's just my
it's just my baggage that I'm carrying
my fear of like losing him
what's that baggage about people in my
life that have left like my dad passed
away when I was like 10 years old
brother moved to Mexico and he's kind of
stuck there just thinking that I'm
getting older trying to slow my roll
find somebody to like build the life
we're reaching 30 which is like 70 and
gay years as they say over 30 over the
hill no we're gonna be old I know my
back is already hurting gays age older
we have more baggage so what were the
biggest issues in the relationship lack
of trust from me what are things you're
curious about if he did cheat on me I'm
curious to know if you did enjoy hanging
out with me that shows why do you have
doubts about that because we weren't
like always affectionate I am curious if
he did love me and if he was just not
able to say it
that we have John here I'm a polygraph
examiner I've tested about 10,000 people
over the last 30-plus years we get the
most accuracy by making sure they answer
yes or no with their mouth only no head
movements or any body movements but
gloves I'm buckled all right I'm gonna
wire you up arms up this will let us
know if the question take your breath
away or if you purposely hold your
breath either ones okay very nervous
ready yes yeah does your mom still hate
me yes
Kru she never really liked Matt even
though it was great she was like this is
not a man from my boy why do you think
so I don't know but maybe she just knew
that it wasn't meant to be I think she
was just jealous of me did you like
having sex with me oh yeah yeah sex was
good did you ever had doubts no but like
I don't know people liable fake it
yeah or you like pretend like you're
into something to make the other partner
happy because you don't know if you'll
reject it or something and we were
dating did you actually think I was
funny
yes crew I think you're funny okay cool
I think everybody too I always tell that
when we were dating I was always topping
but I wanted to bottom and I was kind of
nervous to ask you if I asked you to top
me would you have taught me
yes that's true I was expecting to be
like I'd rather use a strap-on I think I
would have started there made me feel so
embarrassed to ask that it's like
vulnerable to ask for like things that
you want sexually cuz if you get
rejected it feels so personal you could
have trusted me in bed more I asked you
for what I needed
watermelon those are safe word you got a
show at The Improv when we were dating
and I also wanted to get a show there
and I cut in would you have been upset
if I got a show and you didn't know true
Wow oh yeah I would have been happy for
any type of success that you got it
doesn't mean that you took it away from
me it means that you know there's other
chances for me if I don't get it it's a
good way of looking at that yeah I think
because I was so new at the time I was
really antsy and like jealous about
opportunities I want success for all my
friends I think that includes you did
you ever cheat on me during the
relationship No
[Music]
crew whoa that was intense
I didn't think he didn't know who would
ever want to be with you shut your mouth
ha ha I couldn't I tried I tried so hard
to cheat on you do you think it's Matt's
fault that you guys broke up no true
well it's kind of nice
it's my fault why I was just too much I
was too needy and I was too productive I
think jealous ready
tell me nervous did you like touring
with me yes true Oh
oh yeah it's so fun I still wanna go
back to Arizona with you let's do it
without your mom means you might like
you know I'm not banging her my hand
yeah were you using me for your comedy
career no true oh did you enjoy sex with
me yes true oh I enjoyed sex with you to
know that we had good sex
did you like my cooking yes that hit the
top of the computer oh you really did oh
he did it okay I feel like you're not
good at cooking I think I'm a good god I
honestly thought that I did well at the
time but I feel like if you're dating
someone you're just gonna eat what they
put in rather what you do you regret
dating me no true oh oh no I especially
in retrospect I mean it was a lot of fun
kind of forced me to really dive into
comedy because your success with it did
you ever cheat on me with another guy or
guys for that matter
yes true but though it was only one time
wait hold on how do you feel I'm not
surprised but it is overwhelming to hear
it was only one time so it was guy okay
and it was at an airport what it was
flying over Thanksgiving okay and we
didn't have intercourse okay you did it
pretty much I got off the plane and then
we went to the bathroom and then like we
went to wash our hands and we like made
eyes at each other and then I went it
and then he went into a bathroom stall
and I followed him in there and then he
went down on me
Wow and then and then I went to sleep
and waited for my next plane and I kind
of pretended like it didn't happen which
is a little sociopathic but but I don't
really remember what he looks like oh if
I actually feel so much better
it wasn't romantic but I totally cheated
on you yeah you did Wow yeah isn't that
so bad of me but that was towards the
end right yeah well we had just gotten
really sunlight when I went home for
Thanksgiving and I like kind of knew
that we weren't gonna be together and I
think I kind of made that decision in my
mind because right when I got back we
broke up
so in my mind I kind of was like
whatever we're not even gonna meet
together so why not get some dick yeah
I'm about you I mean I think it was a
shitty thing that I did do you feel bad
yeah I do
true oh so you want me to feel bad I do
[Music]
it's not long ago but whatever also it
feels crazy because that doesn't it
feels like something I would never
imagined that I would ever do yeah I
can't believe I did that I have one more
question you never really said it and I
said it to you I said I love you did you
ever love me yes true makes me feel sad
that he couldn't just say it or let the
love grow but I'm glad that I heard it I
definitely know that I did love you but
I know that when you say that out loud
it changes things it like brings it to
another level and I knew I wasn't ready
to do that I'm glad that we didn't just
keep being somewhere where it was gonna
be worse there is a tug of war between
us did you learn anything from all this
I learned that even a year after a
breakup it's still emotional and
visceral you still need closure
Matt would say something nice the way he
said oh it was good affirmation for him
that he like needed but you enjoyed this
right that was my takeaway if that
therapy is good for everyone at any time
in life in our conversation with Matt
earlier just sitting there on the couch
in the span of like 30 minutes he had
some revelations it reinforced my belief
that once you establish that you're
completely honest it's okay to have
issues as long as you trust the other
person if you don't trust your partner
the rest of it has nothing to stand on I
don't regret doing this me and Matt are
such good friends
I couldn't imagine him like not in my
life he's such a great person he's the
person that I fell in love with a cool
that I got to let you know that I did
like love you and have those strong
feelings for you
time that's all good we've never really
like hashed things out and then I have a
post conversation or anything like that
comment below I want to hear your
thoughts who do you think was right who
do you relate to is it anyone's fault or
were they just not meant to be what you
learned that you could apply to your own
relationship and let us know if you want
us to do more of these see you later
[Music]
feels like I'm innocent
[Music]